Hello everybody, this is Session 8 of a new look at cancer.
We're looking at different suppressor systems,
normal program cell deaths.
We talked about receptor site abnormalities.
And now we're going to talk about vitamin D receptors.
Now vitamin D and cancer is very important.
In fact, I believe it was about four years or five years ago though
that the president of Harvard Medical School came out and said,
vitamin D is the number one drug for decreased cancer.
He called it a drug that was his quote.
And I would tend to agree with him.
It's so, so very important.
It is a cell signal.
It's a receptor site stimulator of a poptosis.
It decreases cell growth
and cell proliferation.
It is just a beautiful thing that God gave us.
Vitamin D deficiency is something that we want to look at.
First of all, we'll just chat on that a second.
Most cancer patients have already had their vitamin D levels checked.
Normally, I remember years ago,
vitamin D was considered below 50.
And if you were over 70, you were considered to have too high of vitamin D levels.
Even today, most doctors that you go to, if you have vitamin D levels over 80,
you're going to be told that your vitamin D levels are too high.
In fact, there's multiple studies about vitamin D that talk about,
I think I have a slide presentation on vitamin D in early dementia issues.
And the studies revealed that if your vitamin D levels are below 75,
you have an increased risk.
In fact, the study, the words that they used,
was significantly increased risk in early cognitive decline symptoms.
That means you have it significantly increased risk in early dementia.
So, it is very essential that you follow the guidelines that you want
to vitamin D level between 80 and 150.
So, there was the fear of vitamin D being too high
is that your vitamin D levels are going to be too high
and it could cause kidney stones.
There was one study that showed that back in the 1970s
and that was said refuted by literally thousands of studies
that showed that there was flaws of that study that that does not happen.
It has never actually happened in clinical practice.
So, there's never, ever been a case,
ever in literature of somebody with hyper vitamin D issues causing issues.
Yes, I believe you could have hyper vitamin D issues
if your vitamin D levels were the 200s or something like that
because you were taking a bottle of vitamin D every day.
So, there's, it is a possibility with anything,
but in real life, that's just what you need to be concerned about.
So, getting your vitamin D levels checked,
we see it autoimmune patients that they're always low
because an immune, an autoimmune response tends to just gobble up vitamin D levels,
vitamin D tends to be in an immune autoimmune response,
tends to be a modulator of the immune system.
In a cancer response, tends to be a stimulator of a poptosis
and a blocker of cell proliferation.
So, it's just a win-win-win all the way around.
Where do you normally get vitamin D?
Well, you get it from the sun, right?
So, you're out in the sun getting vitamin D.
Well, there's a couple caveats here.
So, sun affects your skin.
So, number one, you have to have skin exposure
in order to get vitamin D from the sun.
But you have to have seven dehydroxycholesterol in your skin
in order for the sun to convert the seven dehydroxycholesterol
into 25 hydroxy vitamin D.
So, if you do not have adequate amount of cholesterol
circulating in your bloodstream,
then you're not going to make vitamin D in your sun
in your skin.
Matter of fact, you're going to be more prone to burn.
You're going to be more prone to having skin cancer.
Matter of fact, there's arguments that,
oh, I don't want to go out in the sun
because I've had nasal cell carcinoma
and I don't want to end up having skin cancer
because my doctor said the sun causes skin cancer.
Well, the sun can cause skin cancer
if you allow the sun to burn your skin.
So, if you're out in the sun,
you haven't been out in the sun a lot,
you're going to get up with a bird
that you're going to end up with skin cancer.
Or, if you have a decrease concentration of cholesterol,
well, I thought cholesterol was bad.
Is it cholesterol bad by doctor?
Put me a lipitor.
So, my cholesterol, I'm so proud
I have it down to 120.
If you're a cholesterol of 120,
it's too low.
I want my patients to have cholesterol
between 180 and 250.
Cholesterol is the precursor to all your hormones.
Cholesterol is not the bad guy.
Even in arterial plaquing,
it is not the cholesterol that's the bad guy.
It is the inflammation in the intamilining
of the epithelial, endothelial cells
that's causing a blister into the blood vessel
and cholesterol is trying to plac it over
to keep it from bursting cholesterol's the good guy.
Regardless of what the pharmaceutical industry tells you,
cholesterol is not the bad guy.
Yes, you do.
You want cholesterol levels over 350.
No, you don't.
But we want a cholesterol level
that's a high enough concentration
that it could produce your hormones.
Actually, vitamin D is a hormone.
So, if you don't have adequate 70-hydroxycholesterol
in your skin, usually because you're on a lipitor
or some statin drug,
you're not going to be able to produce vitamin D
from your skin
and you're going to be more prone to skin cancer.
So, that's rule number one.
You need adequate amounts of cholesterol in your body.
There's just too many studies that show this.
It's just not a theory anymore.
So, the use of sunscreens is also a bad thing.
First of all, sunscreens have so many cancer-causing chemicals in it
that it's just worthy of an entire presentation in itself.
Do not use commercial sunscreens.
There are some natural sunscreens that are out there
that you could use.
There are some recipes that we put in our presentation on sunscreen
that you could use and make your own natural sunscreen, if you'd like.
So, you need that vitamin D concentration
but you don't want to get burned from the sun.
Problem is, is that I live in Minnesota.
So, there's no way I'm going to get enough vitamin D synthesis
from my skin because I just don't go outside in the winter.
If you go out and expose your skin in the winter in Minnesota,
you're going to have worse problems than vitamin D.
Production, you're going to be dead frostbite.
So, just about everybody in the northern states
is going to need to supplement with vitamin D.
So, what do we do and what do we supplement with vitamin D?
You need a vitamin D3 that is in a oil.
Now, boast products that are out there even at Walmart
and target our vitamin D products.
So, you don't need my products.
Except you need the right dosage.
There's high-fat patients, pretty good products
that have a dosage of vitamin B of 400 IU.
Well, you have to take so many of them to get up to your dosage
that it's just cost prohibitive.
And it's just not realistic.
They're watered down so that they're just not really good products.
But what do the dropper bottles show to this picture?
Is one that I use probably more often than not.
Each drop contains 2,000 IU's of vitamin D.
So, to get your 10,000 that you need in a day,
you need five little drops and it's completely tasteless.
The bottle on the left here is a newer product that we carry
and it's 5,000 per capsule.
So, taking two of those is really easy to get your vitamin D levels.
So, how much should I take? What's my dosage?
Well, typically a person that does not have cancer
in their outside a lot in the summer
or in the southern states,
taking 5,000 IU's a day is usually plenty
to keep your vitamin D levels up.
But I do suggest you get your blood tests
because you can have some other vitamin D conversion defects
that we're not going to get into in this presentation.
So, a person could be taking a lot of vitamin D
and still don't have a very high blood concentration.
Then we got to look at some other issues
with possible vitamin D conversion defects.
If it's in the winter and you do have cancer,
then you should be taking at least 10,000 IU's of vitamin D a day.
Now, if you get your blood checked and you're at 85,
then I would say in the winter still stay at 10,000.
If you're blood, if you check your blood
and you're at 135, then you could probably drop down to 5,000.
But you want to keep it up there.
Many of my patients come into their vitamin D levels
or in the 30's that I put them on 20,000 IU's for a period of time,
maybe a week to a month to get their vitamin D levels up
so that then we could drop them back down to 10,000.
So, this really boosts your immune system.
This really stimulates an immune modulation.
So, if a person has autoimmune issues too,
higher dose vitamin D is definitely the cards for them too.
So, next week, we're going to talk about other things
that we can do to boost our immune system.
So, if you're not on vitamin D, look at that.
Get your blood checked. Talk to your doctor.
If you're not on our patient, then this will be very helpful for you.